wusstest du dass es möglich ist
unzustellbare Amazon Pakete aufzukaufen
man kann sogar schon kleinere Mengen
bestellen und es kann wirklich alles
mögliche drin sein ja und das meiste
nicht alles aber das meiste davon ist
wirklich ungeöffnet ich frage mich auch
ja doch ja alles zu so original verpackt
das sind jetzt 15 Stück und Moment und
hier sind auch noch mal 15 Stück drin
ich habe direkt mal 300 Pakete für knapp
300 € bestellt und wir hatten wirklich
alles mögliche drin hier mal das
teuerste eigene Batterie oder ein Akku
zu sein wie chargeral battery pack das
kostet einfach
89.99 das scheint irgendwas für ein
Dyson Staubsauger zu sein oder so